hey everyone Sal here and I wanted to show you an
in-depth demo of the new AI that we have happening
throughout Khan Academy and what you're going to
see is that it exists in two ways one is helping
students and Learners and teachers with many
of the things that people already familiar with
Khan Academy and as we'll see also introducing a
whole new series of activities that you can now
do with the artificial intelligence so what I see
here what we see here is a classic Khan Academy
exercise but you notice there's this little bot
here so we could click on that I'm here to help
you with this exercise here are a few ideas or
things that you can ask me and you could ask
any of those things but I think what's really
interesting is its ability to be a thoughtful
tutor so if I just say tell me tell me the
answer exclamation mark I'm very entitled here
oh I see you're eager to find the answer but
remember I'm here to help you learn how to
solve it on your own let's start by looking at
the equation what do you think the first step
should be so notice it's really doing what
you would expect a good tutor to be and let
me actually do a mistake here so let's do
three minus this is a common mistake when
Distributing only multiplying it times the
first term minus 18 plus 2m is equal to m
it says oops it looks like there's a small
mistake when you distributed the negative
2 inside the parentheses I put an upside down
smiley face make sure you distribute the negative
2 to both terms in the parentheses the correct
distribution would be this try again let me know
if you need help you got this and then if I
were to write 3 minus 18 minus 4M is equal to m
great job you distributed the negative 2 correctly
this time now you have the following what do you
think the next step should be to solve for M so as
you can tell this is really doing what we think a
really thoughtful tutor would do and this doesn't
just work in math this works across all subjects
that Khan Academy has now it's not just exercises
this is going to sound like an infomercial I'm
going to keep saying and there's more you could do
with this with videos this is just a classic Khan
Academy video that hopefully many of y'all are
familiar with you can do fun things like write
a poem about this video and so notice in both the
previous example where it uh it where I got help
with the problem it already had the context of
the problem it knows what I'm already doing on
Khan Academy likewise here it already knows about
the video it's able to understand what's actually
in the contents of the video it wrote a very nice
poem here in the land of math where equations play
a problem arose one sunny day negative nine minus
9x minus six a challenge to solve a puzzle to fix
on the other hand that's actually as you can see
here that's actually the actual problem that is in
this video on the other side 3 times 4X plus 6 we
must simplify with our math tricks distribute we
must and combine like terms too to find the value
of x that's what we will do and it keeps going on
so that's fun but there's other things you could
do you could say why do I need to learn this
and it asks what are your interests or
goals knowing that will help me explain
how this math concept might be relevant to
you say I really love I don't know soccer
see what it says great in soccer math can
be quite useful especially when analyzing
player performance game statistics and team
strategies understanding equations like the one
in the video can help you grasp more advanced
math concepts which can be applied to soccer
analytics predicting player movements and even
optimizing training routines so learning this is
this math concept can enhance your understanding
and appreciation of the beautiful game and gotta
love the Emojis is doing here so this is
once again across all the videos all the
Articles all the exercises on Khan Academy you can
either you can even do things like this quiz me
and obviously Khan Academy already has a lot of
exercises but here we can just do more and this
is directly related to uh what's going on in the
video but now you know we've just shown how the AI
can be helpful with things that people are already
used to doing on Khan Academy I'll now show how it
can be useful for introducing a whole new series
of activities that uh some of which I think would
have looked like science fiction even a few months
ago so I'm logged in right now as a teacher and
you can see a couple of interesting things here
you can see activities for teachers and you can
also see activities for Learners and we already
have a bunch and we're going to be adding more in
the weeks and months to come but one really
interesting thing and this is an important
safety is you see it says this conversation
is recorded and viewable by your teacher
and we're doing that and if there's a parent
attached to this account it'll say recorded
and viewable by your teacher and your parent or
or your parent and the whole point of that is we
know that the that artificial intelligence large
language models has a lot of power and it can be a
really powerful learning tool as I'm about to show
you but we also want to make sure that there's
proper guard rails we've put a lot of guard
rails into the actual tool we're also being very
careful where we're not passing any personally
identifiable information to the actual artificial
intelligence we are also not using student data
to train it so parents teachers students can rest
assured that this is as safe of an environment
as we can create we're also putting guard rails
around the activities so that students can only
use it to learn and not use it to to cheat but
uh before so as I said parents and teachers
can see everything that students are up to and
if students try to do something that's a little
bit off might be harmful to themselves or others
parents and teachers will be notified but just
to get a sense of the types of activities we can
engage in you have this tutor me activity
which is actually very similar to what we
did in that exercise but here you can get
tutored on pretty much any any subject you
want in math or science or the humanities uh
we could say I want to understand entropy more
ah entropy a fascinating Concept in B indeed to
better understand your current knowledge can you
tell me what you already know about entropy or
what specific aspect you'd like to explore so we
can continue to have a conversation and it acts
like a really good tutor uh this is a fun one
called ignite your curiosity we could pick from
one of these subjects here or you can even put
another approach as long as it's appropriate it
won't let you go to any inappropriate uh topics
hopefully um but let's say you say I want
to explore I want to explore world history
and this is a kind of a way of jumping into the
rabbit hole where it gives you some interesting
questions but you can ask your own questions
at any time as well but says Ah world history a
tapestry of tales woven together through time and
I love the Emojis let's dive into some tantalizing
questions and so we can pick or we could ask
our own what was the real purpose behind the
construction of the Great Wall of China how did
the Silk Road impact the world etc etc I I don't
know I'm kind of curious about that first one the
real purpose of the construction of the Great Wall
of China ah the Great Wall of China a magnificent
Marvel stretching over 13 000 miles the primary
purpose of the Great Wall was to protect China
from Invasion by nomadic times particularly the
Mongols it also helped as a symbol of power and
unity showcasing the strength of the Chinese
Empire so we can keep asking more questions
I could also say why couldn't the Mongols
just go over or around the
wall we put the wall in capital
uh excellent question while the Great Wall
was an imposing structure it wasn't entirely
impenetrable in fact the Mongols did manage to
breach the wall on several occasions however
the wall still served a significant deterrent
and made envisions more and more difficult so
this is just a fun way to really dive deep and
I gotta say again I love I love the Emojis now
beyond that we have practice in pretty much any
subject that a student might want let's say we
wanted to prepare for a trivia night but you could
really put almost anything here that's reasonable
and so it asked you questions in which country
would you find the Great Pyramid of Giza of course
of course going to be Egypt and so great
it matches what's the largest planet of
solar system you could keep going but it
also maybe more importantly has many many
different academic subjects in elementary
school middle school I could go through each
of these both Humanities and stem subjects
middle school high school we have every AP
course here for example I could click on
I don't know let's click on US government
awesome Choice here are 10 top 10 subtopics
in AP US Government that you might want to
be quizzed on so what do we want to do we
could do all of the above I don't know let's
do foundations of American democracy and once
again it is doing quizzing it's going to quiz
me as much as I want and help evaluate me but
I can also ask questions about whenever I want
so the first question what are the key
principles of John Locke's political
philosophy that influenced the founding fathers
when drafting the US Constitution don't worry if
you're not sure I can always give hints or
explain things so let's say give me a hint
so it's centered around the idea of
natural rights and social contract
think about three fundamental rights you
believed all individuals had and how the
government's role is to protect these rights
so let's say the right to the right to property
and to be happy I'm intentionally
not giving it the perfect answer
so it says so it gives its take you know you are
on the right track with the right to property and
happiness the key principles are life liberty
and property which are similar to the phrase
life liberty and the pursuit of happiness found
in the Declaration of Independence great effort
and you could keep going what is the main purpose
of the Federalists to argue for a stronger Central
government
than what we're in the article
well I'll just write it that way
you got it right the Federalist Papers were indeed
written to argue for a stronger central government
so you can quiz yourself as much as you want
on any of these topics I think this will be
particularly uh useful honestly for any student
who's looking to study across subjects stem and
Humanities especially a lot of students preparing
for AP going well into college and Beyond and if
you don't see something that you have here if
you're taking more specialized course you could
just type it in over here we have these
activities where students can debate the
AI or debate Khanmigo or vice versa these are
Elementary School topics like are zoos helpful
or harmful to animals you have Middle School
topics like are cell phones helpful or harmful
in classrooms high school and Beyond topics and
we've populated a bunch of them like should the
student government cancel student debt well
artificial intelligence help or hurt the job
market what you can do is you can take one side
of the issue so let's say let's debate whether
the government should cancel student debt and
I'm just this is you know don't don't send me
mail I'm just taking one point of view to
fine-tune the arguments on either side I
will not tell you my actual opinion but let's
say I'm against I'm against canceling the debt
all right you're against canceling student
debt please go ahead and present your argument
and I'll be ready to counter and present my side
let the debate begin and so we can say canceling
doesn't solve the underlying
issue of expensive College
you cancel for one group and and the next
generation will still accumulate debt let's
see what else could I say oh I could I could
say this is also an insult to those who worked
hard to pay their debt and is a a dis incentive
for others to pay hoping it will be canceled
the real solution is to make College cheaper
and let's see what it responds ah well constructed
argument I see your point about canceling student
debt not addressing the root cause of expensive
college education and I understand how it might
seem unfair to those who have already paid off
their debts however allow me to present the other
side of the coin canceling student debt even if
it doesn't solve the owner and you could see it
keeps going on and on you can spend hours with
this thing and this is just one of the many many
many things you can debate we can chat with
a historical figure for example let's talk to
I don't know let's talk to [Music] um let
me talk to let me talk to George Washington
uh it is an honor to be summoned as the first
president United States George Washington I am
here to share my experiences and answer your
questions as long as they pertain to my time
and context what inquiry do you have for me
my dear fellow and do tell me what interests
you most about my life or the era in which I
lived have you ever been unsure of yourself
indeed there were moments in my life when I
experienced uncertainty and doubt leading the
Continental Army during the American Revolution
was a great responsibility and I often found
myself questioning my decisions however I firmly
believed it was the cause for it was I firmly
believed in the cause for which we fought and I
endeavored to learn from my mistakes and adopt
my strategies accordingly so obviously we could go
on and ask all sorts of things and of course this
is a simulation it's you know to treat it as it is
but there's a lot that we can we can be doing here
literary characters uh there are some here I
could say well you know I like unless I would
love to meet Zeus ah mortal I am Zeus
the king of the Gods and ruler of Mount
Olympus I preside over the sky and thunder and
uphold Justice and law what does thou wish to
know or discuss with me the Mighty Zeus and
what questions what are your insecurities
I've always wanted to know this uh as Zeus the
supreme ruler of the Gods I am not one to dwell
on insecurities however I faced many challenges
in maintaining my rule and ensuring the Loyalty
of my fellow gods and goddesses there have been
times when my authority has been questioned and
I've had to assert my power to maintain order
now mortal tell me about a challenge you have
faced in your life and how you overcame it so
it's nicely driving the conversation but there
is more this is essentially a college coach that
you could talk to about navigating financial aid
how you can pick Majors etc etc also a lot of
fun this is a fun activity that helps combine
reading comprehension and vocabulary and get
a little fact knowledge there so it says you
know let me know what grade level you're
in I don't know let me say I'm sixth grader
it's going to give me 10 vocabulary words it would
be useful for a sixth grader to know and then it's
going to use them it's going to construct passages
and we I can pick what I want the story to be
around so let's say let's make it about um the
Mysterious Island a journey through space and time
all right so what it's doing now is it's
using those vocabulary words one paragraph
at a time and I need to identify which of
those usages were was incorrect so once
upon a time a group of apprehensive explorers
set sail on a daring adventure to find well
apprehensive doesn't sound right that's not what
an Explorer would be so I'll write apprehensive
is wrong should be something
like Brave or Intrepid
whoops
you got it apprehensive doesn't fit the context
and braver Intrepid would be a better choice
great job and so and then it keeps building on
that story about the explorers and it's actually
giving me some content knowledge while we're
doing it this craft a story it's essentially
it helps develop characters and then it trades
off it's an activity that many of y'all might
have seen maybe you've done it with kids or
you've done it with your parents where you
write a paragraph then it writes a paragraph
then you write a paragraph then it writes a
paragraph and you work with the bot to create
a story and we really you know this is really
important to us that we're all about learning and
not about cheating so this isn't about hey just
do the essay for me it's about let's do something
creative together now I promised that it wouldn't
just be for students it's also for teachers they
can develop parts of a lesson like a lesson hook
or exit tickets or entire lesson plans altogether
so ask me what grade I'm teaching let's say I'm
teaching ninth grade I want to teach I'm going
to teach the causes of the Civil of the civil War
oh the cause of the Civil War what a fascinating
thought-provoking topic for ninth graders anyway
would you like me to create a rough draft of
the lesson plan or do you want to provide more
information to customize it further so you can and
you could say whether you want to be Project based
or Hands-On or whether you want to facilitate a
conversation they'll go into all of the details
of what makes a great lesson plan but just for the
sake of this demo I'm just going to say give me a
rough draft just see what it what it can produce
on this and what's interesting is it is producing
a full complete lesson plan that I can take with
9th graders that would be appropriate for them
and it it it produces it and I can then tweak it
if I want them to make it more exciting or make
it more Hands-On or change the assessment um or
or I could I could answer more of its questions
however however wants and you know it's just fun
to see like you know even like some of the hooks
and things it creates begin with a quick pull do
you think the Civil War was a was inevitable why
or why not and encourage students to share their
thoughts briefly and you could ask for a different
type of hook and we even have a lesson hook um
actual activity here this refreshed my knowledge
is forced a teacher uh if hey you know I teach the
Civil War every year but right before I teach it
it's nice to be able to at least make sure that
I have I have a decent handle or I remember all
of the details so let's say I had that lesson
ninth grade ninth grade causes of the Civil War
so quizzing on the topic learning through
conversation let's say I'm quiz quiz me on the
topic so here's like the major the major things
first concept economic and social difference
between the North South can you explain the key
differences between the North and South that
contributed to tensions North was more Industrial
and didn't have slavery South was agricultural
and was dependent on slavery to some degree
that's correct so this is a way I as a
teacher can just make sure that okay and
this works not just in the humanities you
could it could be in the Sciences whatever
you're about to teach you can get the lesson
plan get your hook refresh your knowledge
um and then there's even a couple of fun things
here you can kind of just put stuff about your
classroom here and it can kind of create a fun
poem for what everyone did together and as much
as you already see here and I haven't even gone
through all of all of these activities and I
obviously haven't shown you all the other stuff
on Khan Academy and the related links and how it
can connect what you're doing here to the other
things on Khan Academy we hope to we're already
testing this with teachers and co-designing it
with teachers and Educators working with students
um and this is all right now going to be behind
con Labs we're creating a waiting list for any
of y'all who want to be part of it we are going
to prioritize donors because we do need to fund
the research and development of this but over
the coming months we hope to roll this out to
more and more folks with a priority for schools
in the uh that are already part of the Khan
Academy District offering and we also hope to
release more and more activities for teachers
parents and students hopefully on even a weekly
basis um in the in the months to come so uh I
look forward to for all of you all getting a
chance to uh to Play and Learn with Khanmigo